bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
si on parler sport le T qui est consacré
comme vous le savez à l'actualité
sportive du département et aujourd'hui
elle sera essentiellement tournée vers
les championnats d'Europe de cyclisme
sur PIST qui ont débuté au Vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin en ieline vous connaissez
le concept de l'émission il y aura des
coups de gueule des analystes des débats
et des duels avec nos chroniqueurs ils
sont quatre en plateau aujourd'hui
l'élite du sport Évinois présentation en
musique on commence ce tour de table par
un cycliste il est champion Europe de
cyclisme sur piste Masters il vient tout
juste de décrocher une nouvelle deuxème
place au championnat du monde il est
aussi virvolant et fantasque que le
Slovaque Petter Sagane Yan Dujarier est
avec nous pour cette émission bonsoir
Michel bonsoir Yan alors cette cette
deuxè place champion du monde
masterstisante satisfaisante contrat
rempli on va pas dire encore une fois
mais ouais contrat rempli le le travail
a payé et j'en suis pleinement satisfait
donc il y aura du cyclisme sur piste oui
on vous êtes gâé pour une fois fa la
tête la plupart du temps sur sur le
football le rugby cette émission sera
essentiellement
consacré on prend notre pied ce soir ok
parfait on passe de l'autre côté à
musique lui aussi il est dans le
cyclisme c'est une légende vivante ce
cycliste licencié à véisi a réalisé une
multitude de records son dernier en date
le tééton 2015 où il a pédalé pendant
plus de 24 heures au Vélodrome de
saquanttins en Iline Jean-Michel richfor
nous fait l'honneur d'être sur ce
plateau bonsoiranmichel bonsoir bonsoir
c'est votre grande première c'est une
première c'est une grande première vous
êtes pas trop stressé non non pas du
tout pas du tout puis donc vous êtes un
spécialiste du cyclisme si vous avez des
infos n'hésitez pas en tout cas et ben
on va essayer on va essayer on passe on
repasse à à droite il n'y aura pas que
des pros du vélo sur cette émission un
rugby man versill sera aussi parmi nous
il est un adepte des chistera mais aussi
des trè mitemps il n'a pas pris de
corticoïde avant d'arriver sur cette
émission Guillaume ner est avec nous
bonsoir Guillaume bonsoir Michel je vois
que vous surfez bien sur
laactalitétique ça vous inspire quelque
chose cette actualité ils ont été
blanchi blanchi parfait tout va bien
donc vous n'avez rien à rajouter on
parle de cyclisme vous êtes rug ça ne
vous pose pas de problème sur cette
émission j'ai des chose à dire aussi on
termine notre tour de table à gauche il
est le président de l'équipe de football
de trap c'est l'un des hommes les plus
influents dans le monde du sport
evelinois Franck maccour le nouvel
nouveau actionnaire de l'OM lui aurait
demandé des conseils pour gérer son club
de football Mustapha lbaoui le président
du club de football de Trap est avec
nous Mustapha bonjour c'est une rumeur
Fran macourt qui vous demande des
conseils pour gérer le club complètement
je suis dédié je suis dédié totalement
mon club donc quels que soient les les
faveurs qu'on pourrait m'accorder je
reste au à l'Étoile Sportive de trappe
quel que soit zé après absolument
absolument on a souvent défendu les
valeurs du sport ici et déccrié les
problèmes d'argent qu'on avait dans ce
sport c'est pas moi qui vais m'y mettre
et vous le savez Messieurs au passage
c'est sur ordonance au passage les
corticoing c'est sur ordonnance on va
passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler comme vous l'aurez compris
essentiellement des championnats
d'Europe de cyclisme sur piste nous
parlerons de cette nouvelle génération
française nous feront un focus sur le
vélodrome de SaintQuentin en Yveline
mais notre premier débat concerne
l'exclusion des têtes d'affiches
françaises Grégory booget Michel Delma
et François
Pervis les championnats d'Europe ont
débuté au Vélodrome de 5tins en ilvine
un événement exceptionnel qui se
déroulera sans les têtes d'affiche des
derniers gios de Rio les médailles de
bronze Grégory boget originaire de
maison la fite ligne MONT à François
perv et le plaisiroi Michel delmeda ont
été sanctionnés pour leur comportement
pendant les Jeux explication avec le
directeur technique national Vincent
Jaquet les Jeux Olympiques ça doit être
une un but ultime une fête ça doit être
une
une un projet sportif qu'on doit qu'on
doit aborder en plein partage avec ses
staffs avec son entraîneur avec ses
coéquipiers on va pas aux Jeux
Olympiques on travaill indépendant c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible c'est un
travail d'équipe ce que je regrette
c'est que cette
équipe n'est pas n'it pas eu ce
supplément d'âme pour non pas partir en
vacances ensemble mais aller chercher
cette victoire et mettre tous les moyens
pour aller chercher cette victoire au
niveau du collectif il y a eu un
problème de comportement vis-à-vis du
staff Grégory beoget a notamment annoncé
ne pas avoir été assez préparé qui
n'avait pas été mis dans les meilleures
conditions on écoute le DTN Vincent
jacquer sur la question il prépar leur
vélo tous les jours il passent des
heures et des heures dans l'atelier et
derrière et derrière pour se prendre le
staff a pas été à la hauteur on a eu des
problèmes de
staff le
staff n'a pas su n'a pas su répondre à
mes attentes c'est insupportable en
voyant ces deux interviews peut-on dire
qu'il fallait sanctionner les pistestars
après les gios décevants vous votez oui
ou
non non vous êtes partagé y vous votre
côté on va faire un petit duel entre
vous Jean-Michel et et vous Jean-Michel
vous commencez oui sanctionner après
coup je sais pas si c'était judicieux
lorsqu'on prépare les Jeux Olympiques
c'est 1 an à l'avance 6 mois à l'avance
j'ai vu le staff donner beaucoup tous
les mécanaux qui ont préparé et ce qui
m'énerve un
peu du vu les déclarations de Grégory
bauget c'est de dire c'est toujours de
la faute des autres je me souviens à
Londres après la finale perd du c'était
soi-disant de la faute des roues
françaises et cetera toujours l'excuse
et même si c'est un très grand champion
moi j'admire parce que c'est un champion
c'est un battant grégoryi beoget mais à
un moment donné on ne peut pas toujours
reporter sur les autres quant à à
l'esprit d'équipe ils n'ont pas eu
d'esprit d'équipe parce que depuis 6
mois on les voit travailler toutes les
semaines dans le Vélodrome et ils sont
chacun de leur côté il s'entraînent il
ne partageent pas il ne communique pas
donc là euh bon c'est c'est pas bien
parce que c'est pas la meilleure façon
de préparer et sachant que c'est un tout
il y a le staff il y a les entraîneurs
il y a les mécanaux il y a les soigneurs
les masseurs et puis les coureurs
également et on partage également avec
les remplaçants ce n'était pas le cas
mais sanctionner après coup je il
sanctionner sur le moment non c'est pas
sanctionner faire comprendre faire de la
pédagogie les réunir toujours ensemble
on partage on a tout à se dire quand on
travaille en équipe dans une équipe et
ça c'est le propre du du sporco en rugby
en football donc quand quelque chose va
pas on se le dit et là ce sont des des
petites équipes mais les éegoos ont pris
la dimension donc sur le collectif c'est
dommage mais après coup ça sert à rien
parce que François Pervis a été six fois
champion du monde grégoryi beoget a été
champion du monde et de quelle manière
encore une fois à neu reprises et de
quelle manière la dernière fois que ce
soit Pervis ou boget à Saint-Quentin
donc ils ont défendu la France alors
sanctionner non Yan qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à Jean-Michel je suis
complètement d'accord avec Jean-Michel
c'est vrai que moi
je pas parce effet c'est ça moi provquer
un duel je pour moi il y a pas de
sanction en plus pour moi il y a même
pas de sanction parce que aujourd'hui
François Pervis est à au Japon fait sa
tournée kirine donc je suis pas sûr
qu'il avait prévu de faire les
championnats d'Europe François Pervis
qui a quand même réagi sur les réseaux
sociaux on va le voir sûrement à l'image
un tweet de François Pervis il est
vraiment
de ne pas être de ne pas être
pris VO je pense que ce nétait pas le
cas de tous les athlètes je pense qu'il
y en AVC qui avait pas prévu de venir
faire les championnat d'Europe moi je
trouve que on en parlera plus tard mais
je trouve que c'est c'est une bonne
opportunité pour pour d'autres donc
voilà on parle unu dans émission et mais
mais voilà je pense pas que ce soit une
sanction de ne pas les apporter VO le
tweet justement de François Pervis
visiblement toutes les vérités ne sont
pas bonnes à dire heureusement que j'en
ai dit que 10 % les choses doivent
peut-être dite si on veut avancer alors
là par oui il est déçu et et alors là je
le rejoins parce que en effet si ils
veulent pouvoir avancer et continuer
d'apporter ce qu'ils doivent apporter à
l'équipe de France et ce qui a été le
rôle de de Florian Rousseau à une époque
quand il accompagnait les jeunes en
effet ils doivent percer les absè ou
percer les problématiques qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer moi je pense que la le plus
gros de la problématique vient du fait
que une dans un dans un dans une
préparation pour une tel n'importe quel
échéance il doit y avoir une vraie
osmose entre un entraîneur et son et son
alète qu'il doit y avoir une confiance
mutuelle entre les deux il doit y avoir
de la communication c'estàdire que
l'athlète doit avoir confiance en son en
son entraîneur mais il doit pas non plus
boire tout ce que l'entraîneur lui dit
si jamais il y a un désaccord ils
doivent pouvoir il doivent pouvoir en
parler mais il y a quand même un moment
où il faut qu'ils avancent tous les deux
dans le même sens et là on parle d'une
équipe parce que donc on n pas 50
entraîneurs dans l'équipe de France il y
un équipe de il y a un entraîneur de
l'équipe de sprint il avait ils étaient
deux d'ailleurs avec avec le Gané et et
et franc du rrivau donc il faut que tout
ça ça doit être une ça doit être une une
mécanique qui doit être hyper bien
huilée et tout doit avancer tout doit
avancer naturellement et là il y a trop
de nit pour faire en sorte que tout tout
aille bien Guillaume je vous vois
vraiment bouillonner là depuis quelques
minutes ch j'ai noté trois choses sur ma
petite tablette là pas pour message mais
premièrement euh on parle de tête
d'affiche alors tête d'affiche c'est
leur passé peut-être mais c'est le
dernier résultat il y a pas tê d'affiche
en France euh premièrement d'accord il y
a 2 ans François perd a quand même
remporté deux tites de champion du monde
dernière é il est très fort euh ensuite
on parle d'ego forcément quand on fait
un sport individuel il y a des egoos
surdimensionnés bien plus que les sport
collectif et donc forcément c'est plus
compliqué à gérer et dernière chose la
DTN parle mais est-ce que elle elle s
mise en question ça je sais
pas marqué également un petit un petit
message sur votre petite tblette jeis je
l'avais noté pour mémoire pour
que Guillaume puisse s'en servir et il
et le mémoriser mais on est d'accord
tous les deux relevez-le un petit peu on
est d'accord tous les deux euh
j'ai l'IM alors la question c'était
est-ce qu'il faut sanctionner après coup
jeais y répondre parce que visiblement
personne ne l'a fait autour de cette
table je m'en charge voilà non c'est
juste que on sanctionne pas ce genre de
chos pour une raison simple c'est que on
fait comme si en tous les cas à la tête
du DTN ou à la tête des
institutions le sport n'était pas
pratiqué par des hommes et des femmes et
par définition s' y a une dimension
importante dans le sport c'est aussi la
personnalité voir l'individualité qui
peut y avoir et souvent LGO donc ça se
traite et ça se traite avant en clair
que ça soit dans un sport collectif et
j'ai j'apprécie beaucoup ce que dit
Jean-Michel clairement on est dans une
équipe mais l'équipe c'est pas
simplement ce qui joue il y a le
Président il y a le staff technique il y
a l'encadrement bref il y a toute une
équipe qui est pas simplement celle qui
pratique et qui est visible et par
définition c'est un travail d'équipe
mais ça reste également des options
parfois individuelles et en même temps
euh bah ça ça doit être traité donc s'il
y a quelque chose qui doit être traité
dans le sport c'est bien l'individu par
définition c'est vrai dans le foot on a
des stars entre guillemets on les gère
vous en avez on les traite on sanctionne
pas ce genre d'attitude par contre c'est
vrai que s'il y avait quelques
débordement que ce soit ben un moment
donné on peut le sanctionner d'une autre
manière c'est-à-dire que faire en sorte
que et là et là on revient sur ce que
dit Guillaume c'est qu'à un moment donné
il faut aussi montrer pour le coup des
résultats vite fait euh quand on quand
on parle de staff moi je me souviens
d'image où quand donc vous avez
l'athlète qui prend un titre au
championnat du monde mais tout le monde
est hyper content pour lui quoi et se
dit on a tous bossé et il a
réussi quand ils sont aux Jeux
olympiques et qu'il se ratent les
mécanos ils sont aussi blasés quoi parce
qu'ils ont bossé autant ouais mais le
résultat il est pas là vous comprenez
Vincent Jaquet qui se sent offensé
offensé enfin déçu enfin qu'il soit déçu
parce que les résultats sont pas au bout
sont pas au bout gère ça se gère mais
c'est à lui de le gérer JeanMichel hier
soir j'ai eu la chance d'assister à la
médaille deors
de de Quentin lafar sur le K et à la
descente de la piste à côté il y avait
son mécano son entraîneur et les deux
avaient les larmes aux yeux donc là
c'est ce sont des images fortes B le
résultat est là mais là j'ai senti que
il y avait un partage un partage entre
tous les auteurs donc d'une performance
parce que l'athlète seul n'est rien s'il
n'a pas autour de lui donc un entourage
don manqué peut-être de tact dans ces
dans ces attaques les les propos après
c'est c'est fait quoi il y a pas eu les
performances il y avait une médaille à
Rio mais avec des sill on refait le
monde mais encore une fois maintenant il
faut préparer l'avenir le passé ce n'est
pas sur les polémiques qu'on va
construire Guillaume est-ce que c'est
pas un moyen aussi de se cacher derè le
fait de pas de pas les sélectionner pour
n résultat sportifs aussi peut-être
qu'ils sont pas non mais
peut-êtrejourd'hui sont plus au niveau
par rapport et lancer une nouvelle
génération voilà et c'est se caché aussi
derrière en disant B il faut le dire euh
clairementc une fois pas dit on s'est
réunit on dit bon mais merci messieurs
vous avez donné pour pour la nation
maintenant on va préparer Tokyo avec la
nouvelle génération ce que font de
nombreuses nations et la relève est là
vous connaissez les noms vous allez
partager et tout ce que vous avez appris
et bien essayez de le transmettre aux
jeunes parce que encore une fois quand
on a un maillot de l'équipe de France on
ne représente plus soi mais c'est la
nation hein c'est une médaille pour pour
pour son pays mustapa on se prive quand
même de grands champions ouais on se
prive probablement de grands champions
mais les champions c'est aussi des gens
qui sont étanches c'est qu'à un moment
donné je parlerai pas forcément du cas
présent à la limite on illustre un vrai
sujet c'est celui de l'étanchéité à la
fois des staffs et des auteurs quand je
parle d'étanchéité c'est qu'à moment don
il y a des choses qui peuvent rester en
interne les grandes entreprises le
savent la communication c'est important
je trouve que le sport se grandirait
qu'on arrête ces petites phrases qu'on
arrête ce déballage parce que ils ont
chacun les uns les autres des arguments
à faire valoir simplement c'est les
inéressés on les a pas en face ça
pourrait prendre beaucoup de temps donc
je pense que tout le monde se grandirait
dans tous les sport en général alors je
sais que ça plaît au journalisme je sais
que ça plaît à ceux qui gravitent autour
mais en même temps ces gens-là doivent
savoir qu'il y a du journalisme autour
pour faire encore une fois mettre en
avant le sport c'est ce qu'on réclame
tous mettez en avant les sports qui
soient visible simplement quand on est
visible bah on est pas simplement
visible on est également écouté on est é
pied donc à un moment donné il faut se
se professionnaliser aussi sur cette
dimension je parle à la fois des acteurs
et des gens qui encadrent le sport se
grandirait que les choses se traitent
autrement mais ça permet de parler aux
téléspectateurs de ce qui se passe dans
la réalité euh des des vestiaires et des
et des des entreprises sportives ouais
on gère de l'humain on gère de la
psychologie on gère pas simplement des
performances et des chiffres donc c'est
c'est le moyen d'en parler pour rentrer
un peu dans l'intimité mais je trouve
que les gens se grandiraient de
d'arrêter un peu ce genre de spectacle
malgré cette mise à l'écart la porte est
quand même toujours ouverte pour les
trois sportifs comme l'a indiqué le DTN
on l'écoute la porte est toujours
ouverte j'ai besoin d'un projet j'ai
besoin d'une vision j'ai besoin du
respect du cadre c'est tout ce que je
demande parce que clairement ils vous
ont manqué de respect ils ont manqué de
respect à la Fédération c'est logique
que la porte soit toujours ouverte selon
vous Jean-Michel richchoir oui parce que
n'oublions pas que par exemple nickel
dalmeda encore il a 28 ans il est au
sommet de sonard et il a encore des
choses à prouver donc il a toute sa
place dans dans cette équipe pourquoi
pas Grégory bet également même François
Pervis donc après il est toujours bon
d'avoir un de coureur et après ben c'est
la performance qui parle à un moment
donné on sélectionne les meilleurs du
moment pour la compétition du moment je
voudrais juste faire un rappel a gagné
son dernier titre de champion olympique
en kerine à 35 ans voilà donc François
perv ils sont ils sont dans la course
ils sont dans la course pour pour le
Japon voel dans des conflits armé dans
des conflits armé dans le monde on
laisse la porte ouverte à la diplomatie
pour faire en sorte que les choses
s'apèisent je crois pas qu'on soit à ce
niveau de de guerriia ou de guerre
civile pour qu'on arrive à fermer des
portes donc oui bien sûr il faut
toujours laisser la porte ouverte mais
en même
temps'cuseel j'en sais Ren parce que je
je suis pas dans la enc je connais pas
la qualité des propos des propos
affichés mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
la porte doit rester ouverte pour les
deux mais ils doivent pour une porte
quand elle est ouverte c'est pour que
certains en sortent et d'autres en
rentrent c'est entre guillemets c'est
c'est mutuel et surtout c'est un métier
la sélection alors les meilleurs du
moment oui mais c'est les meilleurs du
moment pas simplement sportif encore une
fois on a vu dans des équipes de
football pour en revenir à ma discipline
où on a vu les meilleurs peluer le
collectif donc moi je sais pas ce que
c'est que le meilleur du moment le
meilleur du moment c'est les résultats
sportifs la physiologie qui fonctionne
bien mais il y a également le mental et
puis tout ce qui va drainer autour donc
c'est un métier qui fasse le leur
guillaumez la même qure figure dans
votre club à Versailles vous réagissez
comment Paron
même cas de
figure figure avec je sais pas a des
joueurs qui critiquent le staff oh bah
ça ça arrive tous les ans ça c'est
facile quand ça gagne pas ça critique le
staff quand ça gagne tout le monde est
beau tout le mond est gentil donc après
nous on n pas la même ils le disent
entre eux en 3è mi-temps parce que je
suis à de 3è mi-temps apparemment donc
ils le disent entre eux l'alcool un
petit peu à parler aussi donc voilà mais
après
c'est tout est une question de oui
dangereux pour la santé santé mais non
mais tout est une question Mustapha il a
raison sur de dire que il a y a des
sélections de foot ou de rugby et cetera
où on a on s'est passé des meilleur pour
que l'ambiance d'équipe soit meilleure
et que les résultat soit amélioré
peut-être aussi que le cyclisme sur PIST
devrait penser à ça enfin pense à ça
aussi en disant tout le monde oua même
si c'est les meilleur est-ce que c'est
est-ce que ils apportent vraiment un
plus à l'équipe ou finalement est-ce
qu'ils freinent
l'équipe ça sera le mot de la fin sur ce
premier thème on va à présent parler à
notre deuxième thématique elle concerne
toujours le monde du cyclisme l'actuel
président de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme David l'appartient en post
depuis 2009 a annoncé juste avant le
début des championnats d'Europe qui ne
se représenteraient pas en mars prochain
pour être élu à la tête de la FFC il
nous explique son choix ayant réalisé
deux mandats à la tête de la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme je suis élu dans
cette association dans cette fédération
depuis 20 ans et mon implication au
niveau international en tant que
président de l'Union européenne de
cyclisme vice-président de l'Union
cycliste international et président du
Conseil du cyclisme professionnel me
demande de plus en plus de temps et ça
me paraît de plus en plus difficilement
compatible avec la conduite d'une
fédération aussi grande que la nôtre et
donc j'ai choisi de faire cette annonce
à 5 mois moi du scrutin pour que celles
et ceux qui entendent Briger la
présidence de la fédération bien
puissent le faire avec suffisamment de
temps pour présenter leur projet au club
au délégués et à l'ensemble des
départements et des régions la question
sur ce thème son départ peut-il
déstabiliser les sportifs sur ces
championnats d'Europe vous votez oui ou
non pareil Jean-Michel non oui non non
c'est c'est non c'est rouge je vais pas
y arriver donc moi c'est non vous êtes
tous unanimes Jean-Michel non parce que
ça n'a rien à voir enfin il y a le volet
sportif et le volet organisation d'une
fédération avec une structure
administrative avec des élections toutes
les Olympiades alors je pense que le
président de la Fédération a très bien
fait d'annoncer
euh de façon à ne prendre personne au
dépourvu de façon à préparer une autre
équipe qui je pense est en cours de de
préparation actuellement mais ça n'a
aucune incidence sur l'annonce d'une
sélection euh à quelques jours avant les
les championnats d'Europe le timing
est-il bon oui le timing est bon parce
que les élections de de la FFC auront
lieu fin février début mars je crois
début mars 2017 donc il faut préparer
une succession se prépare mais ça ne se
prépare pas 3 mois avant ou 3 semaines
avant ça se prépare 5 6 mois avant c'est
ce que souhaite le président
l'appartient je pense et c'est une bonne
chose Mustapha non non mais pour vous
qui êtes Président vous auriez fait la
même chose pour le coup c'était le le
bémol que je voulais apporter parce
qu'on a tous dit que ça finalement ça
n'allait pas
déstabiliser ce serait presque laissé à
penser que le président sert à rien
aussi bien quel que soit le sport donc
il s'en va et alors s' on l'a vu on l'a
vu à bien des égards dans d'autres dans
d'autres sports ou dans d'autres dans
d'autres rubriques mais non c'est le
seul BM que je l' apporté mais
Jean-Michel l'a dit très bien ça se
prépare parce que sinon ça peut être une
cata pour une raison très simple c'est
pas qu'il est indispensable dans
l'exercice de du sport mais il est
indispensable pour tous les rouages dans
le club et puis il y a une deuxième
dimension très très simple à à
comprendre c'est que si on veut parler
cyclisme bah on parle pas de politique
du club on parle cyclisme si on passe
son temps à faire de la politique on
fait pas autre chose donc c'est très
déstabilisant quand c'est pas préparé
donc à partir du moment où ça l'est ça
peut être même un un rebond de avec une
notoriété différente enfin ça peut être
un plus pourqui tamier gu bon parce que
s'il av fait après les je sais pas
d'Europe enfin je veux dire que là sa
décision est h hors résultat quoi enfin
dire c'est un choix alors sil avit fait
après on aurait pu croire que c'était à
cause du résultat machining est bon
c'est avant au moins il est il est il
est régl tout le monde je pars avant et
quel que soit résultat de je sais pas
d'urope je pars je fais mon taf pendant
de de de mandats maintenant je là ça la
passe au suivant mais voilà moi je
trouve le timing est bon d'accord vous
pense la même chose bien sûr j'ai qu le
bateau en pleine crise on peut le dire
quasiment en pleine
crise attention en pleine crise pour le
cyclisme sur piste mais le cyclisme
c'est pas juste la piste hein c'est la
route c'est le BMX le VTT le donc non
non il a fait énormément de choses
pendant ces ans le vélodrome le
vélodrome qui est là il est pas il est
pas il est pas innocent dedans on va en
sortir à nouveau en Bretagne dans sa
commune dans sa commune en ouais dans
dans sa commune en Bretagne c'est c'est
ce que je le parce qu'il est également
conseiller général aussi voilà il est
mer mer de sa
communee il
également il est également président de
l'Union européne
également un viceprésident sur du
cyclisme mondial ça fait beaucoup ça
fait beaucoup donc voilà il a énormément
de casquette et en effet ça fait
beaucoup mais il le dit il ne peut pas
se consacrer et c'est une grande
fédération une fédération olympique avec
de multiples disciplines et puis des
structures des clubs n'oublions pas que
sur son projet un cyclisme Conquérent
donc qu'il a avancé avec bien sûr son
comité directeur et puis tout tout tout
le staff la FFC a progressé je crois de
de 16000 licenciés donc c'est son bilan
est positif selon vous son bilan euh oui
il est globalement positif bien sûr il y
a encore des chantiers des des des
chantiers dans tous les domaines au
niveau du cyclisme amateur au niveau des
clubs au niveau des organisations de la
sécurité des organisations euh bon parce
que une fédération avant tout s'occupe
essentiellement du cyclisme amateur et
et du haut niveau bien sûr avec les
échéances championnat d'Europe
championnat du monde je Jeux olympiques
mais oui c'est une fédération qui est
sur de bons rail maintenant il faut il
faut préparer l'avenir après cette page
débat on passe maintenant à notre coup
de
projecteur on en a parlé à précédemment
les têtes d'affiche Grégory boget Michel
dalmeda et François perver ont été
écarté de la sélection pour mener à
cette équipe de France les dirigeants
ont voulu insuffler un peu de fraîcheur
et de la jeunesse les pistars tricolores
sont mené par un Quentin lafar qui a
seulement 25 ans et des petits jeunes
sur l'endurance comme Sébastien Vigier à
Benjamin Tomas ou encore Florient maîre
les trois ont entre 19 et 21 ans on
écoute le DTN Vincent Jaquet sur la
question si je ne lance pas dans le
grand bain les jeunes dès la première
année du début de l'olympiade jamais je
vais le faire donc effectivement on est
là pour acquérir l'expérience se
confronter monter d'un niveau et
derrière ne pas oublier que les grands
champions qui qui ont fait ces 10
dernières années ont encore une place
sauf que aux Europe ce sont les jeunes
qui qui passent là faut-il miser sur la
jeunesse desè ces championnats d'Europe
vous votez oui ou non non vous êtes
encore
unanimeter en
fait évid guillum petit allez on va
partir voulais faire un Ave mais il aura
pas
de on est tous d'accord c'est une
évidence qu'après un une olympiade raté
enfin des j ratés il faut il faut ins
sou nouveau et et penser à la prochaine
olympiade donc d'entr jeu préparer les
les jeunes à VI des premières gances
européennes déjà avec la pression et
tout ce qui va avec en plus à domicile
donc à domicile ça enfin ça va faciliter
un peu leur intégration on a toujours un
petit ple mandame à domicile qui à
l'extérieur ENF en tout cas en sport C
je pense que c'est pareil en en sport
individuel donc ouais c'est une évidence
il faut il faut le faire c'est le moment
pour le faire quoi Jean-Michel oui c'est
le bon moment et on l'a vu hier toutes
les les nations
étrangères les grandes nations font de
même on a vu les Anglais avec donc ce
n'est pas un cas spécifiquement français
non non non avec euh bien sûr il y aura
toujours les cadres dans dans une équipe
il y a des ces mais c'est le moment donc
d'intégrer les jeunes avec l'échéance à
4 ans donc Tokyo et des Nation des
nations amèent des des jeunes de 17 ans
sur sur ce championnat d'Europe ouais
voilà on l'a vu on on les a on en a vu
quelquesuns hier et et ce sera un peu
pour pour ce sera le cas pour pour
beaucoup de nations il faut pas oublier
que donc oui on va parler de Sébastien
Vigier qui a qui a 19 a déjà gagné des
des manches de Coupe d'Europe sur piste
donc c'est c'est pas un novice donc
c'est bien de le mettre sur un
championnat d'Europe euh c'est c'est
c'est il y a moins de pression peut-être
sur un championnat d'Europe pour pour
les jeunes non non non non là pour eux
pour eux ils sont là pour faire leur
place ils sont là pour faire leur pour
pour montrer l'écro et montrer qu'il
faudra compter sur eux sur eux par la
suite même sur un championnat de France
Sébastien Vigier fait 3e du championnat
de France dans vitesse derrière Quentin
et et Charlie Conor euh il est là pour
pour dire les gars vous pouvez commencer
à compter sur moi je vais je vais venir
vous je vais venir vous vous pousser
quoi donc c'est c'est c'est eux qui vont
permettre aussi à c'est lui qui va
permettre à Quentin d'aller chercher des
performances qui vont être plus fortes
pour pouvoir aller chercher des titres
mondiaux olympique c'est c'est la
nouvelle génération qui il se poussent
tous les uns les autres Mustapha cette
émulion au sein de l'équipe de France
avec les petits jeunes qui poussent vous
pensez que c'est une bonne chose pour
quasent c'est quasiment une vocation
même de de la féd c'est une vocation
pour tous les présidents de club des
présidents de fédération du sport tout
simplement parce qu'à un moment donné il
y a des limites physiques puisque on
parle encore une fois sportif et par
défition voilà il y a ceux qui les
limites physiques par définition il y a
ceux qui sont en devenir donc c'est une
vocation pour nous et voilà que ça soit
dans le cyclisme pareil dans le rugby ou
dans le football on aime à on aime à
surclasser nos gamins avec toujours
quand même la précaution c'est que ça ça
peut être parfois destructeur puisque
par définition s'il est pas mal s'il est
mal préparé et là on revient à ce qu'on
a dit tout à l'heure on fait confiance à
des gens qui font bien leur boulot mais
bien faire son boulot c'est les
accompagner voir les surclassés tout en
vérifiant que il ils on tireront profit
pour eux même d'abord Guillaume ou puis
en même temps je pense que tous ceux qu'
on fait les Goos étaient pas préparés
pour faire les enfin autant prépar
physique c'est ça donc donc c'est aussi
le moment de faire tourner sauf Flor
Berton qui qui a réussi quand même à
décrocher une médaille de bronze tout à
fait
lor fait les championnats d'Europe avec
une reprise une reprise de
l'entraînement 3 semaines avant les
championnat d'Europe elle a PR voilà il
sont dit vacances d'Ur par contre
j'avais une question c'est c'est quoi le
coup de projecteur c'est flipant quand
même d'accord rien à voir avec le coup
de projecteur qu'on pourrait
éventuellement recevoir j'attendais
patiment tout à l'heure non c'est juste
fallait la faire fait attention en tout
cas faites attention en tout Casha on
prépare déjà les gios de Tokyo selon
vous Mustapha ah bah clairement
clairement à la sortie des des Jeux
olympiques de Rio on prépare déjà Tokyo
pourquoi perdre du temps pour le coup
c'est vraiment perdre du temps donc on
se prépare toujours d'une échéance à
l'autre j'ai même entendu dire qu'on
prépar c'était déjà presque trop tard
pour préparer Tokyo qu'on était déjà sur
la préparation 2024 et on sait pas où on
va d'ailleurs le directeur technique le
disait luimême il le disait lui-même
j'ai besoin de me projeter j'ai besoin
d'un vision cette vision là il l' par le
calendrier donc à vous d'accrocher les
wagons c'est c'est très important alors
on peut se poser la question de est-ce
judicieux d'avoir des Championnats
d'Europe en octobre après l'échéance
olympique là je pense que ça tombe ça
tombe
mal c'est vraiment ridicule tout
simplement parce qu'en plus cette année
les championnats du monde vont être très
tard dans la saison euh à enfin en Corée
ou un pays dans un pays asiatique et ils
vont avoir lieu au mois d'avril au mois
de mai al alors que normalement ils ont
lieu févri donc il sont très très loin
dans la saison et en effet on aurait pu
simplement mettre les championnats
d'Europe plutôt au mois de février si
mois de février une échéance pour
préparer les championnats du monde là
c'est vraiment trop tôt pour les
athlètes qui sortent qui sortent des
jeux olympiqu en tout cas les résultats
ne sont pas mauvais pour le moment les
Français ont un objectif entre 6 et
médailles sur ces championnat d'urope
ils ont remporté deux premières
médailles sur cette première journée
avec Lori Berton avec le bronce de Laor
Berton sur l'élimination et Quentin
lafarg a lui raflé l'or sur le kilomètre
il ne voulait pourtant pas assumer son
rô de leader écoutez c'est vous qui m'a
annoncé en leader moi je suis un
coéquipier qui se font dans une équipe
de France qui est en train de se
recréer je suis du coup bah j'étais le
plus jeune l'anné dernière je suis un
des plus anciens cette année et bah
voilà j'ai un petit peu d'expérience y
vous comprenez qu'il ne veuilleent pas
assumer son rôle de leader France il
vient juste de le dire c'est que ça lui
tombe dessus un petit peu très
rapidement c'était le plus jeune l'
année dernière aujourd'hui c'est le plus
vieux par contre c'est quelqu'un de très
sympa Quentin lafarg et donc il va
prendre ce rôle avec avec le plus grand
sérieux et il le fera avec grand plaisir
de donner parce que il donne même à des
anciens comme comme moi puisque c'est le
parrain de mon team de mon team sprint
mais mais donc il va il va leur donner
des conseils il va les accompagner après
enfin accompagner il y a que dans en
vitesse il qu' en a qu'un accompagner
c'est Sébastien Viger hein puisque
Benjamin Edelin même s'il est jeune ça
fait Quême un moment qu'il est qu'il est
là Charlie Conor a le même âge que que
Quentin donc il y a pas de il y a que
Sébastien à qui vient découvrir le haut
niveau le niveau européen mais qui a
aussi déjà officier à ce à ce niveau-là
sur des coupes d'Europe Mustapha à quel
moment on peut envisager être un leader
à quel moment il a 25 ans il faut
attendre encore un peu pour pour le coup
c'est pas le moment qui le détermine
c'est la performance donc à quel moment
c'est quand il quand il en sera quand il
en sera pour le coup devant les
résultats mais il y a pas de timing pour
ça il y a juste la performance ça fait
quand même 3 ans qu'il est champion de
France il vient de briller son premier
titre de champion d'Europe il en était
quand même très très content je pense
que il va pas finir sa moisson ici avec
les le reste le reste sur le reste du
weekend et euh et donc il va il va
prendre au fur et à mesure que les jours
vont passer il va prendre la dimension
et et il va leur apporter il va leur
apporter tout ça je vous propose à
présent une séquence émotion une belle
image de ces championnats d'Europe Lori
Berton vient de décrocher une médaille
de bronze une petite déception pour la
championne qui visait l'or et son
compagnon Quentin la FARG a décidé de la
réconforter voilà vraiment beau c'est
mignon mapha
ouis bien sûr c'est quand il y a de
l'affection voilà que ça soit dans le
sport globalement c'est ce qu'on
recherche on cherche des émotions et en
charge de l'affection bien évidemment et
donc ça fait plaisir ça le cyclisme
Jean-Michel oui c'est ça le cyclisme
alors pour Laor on est tous très
contents de de cette médaille mais il
faut savoir que sur une épreuve comme
les tion c'est une épreuve aléatoire et
on peut faire 5e 7e 3e on peut gagner
hier soir elle a fait une course
parfaite mais je crois qu'à la fin bon
les les les deux filles qui l'ont battu
étaient très très fortes et quand on se
confronte à la fin à à une championne
olympique championne du monde également
en titre donc là il y a rien à dire mais
Lori à la pointure il y a pas de souci
on passe maintenant à notre deuxème coup
de projecteur M il concerne le vélodrome
de 50 ans en ivline il monte en
puissance depuis son inauguration en
2014 il a déjà organisé deux événements
internationaux le vélodrome est-il
devenu la capitale du cyclisme en France
avant de répondre à cette question on
regarde cette séquence le vélodrome
s'installe tout simplement on a prouvé
avec les championnats du monde que nous
avions une arène
internationale un vélodrome une piste
vraiment très très appréciée des
sportifs donc nous avons le souhait de
continuer peut-être pas avec un
événement international tous les ans
mais de continuer régulièrement et aussi
de montrer que nous sommes prêts
particulièrement pour Paris 2024
aujourd'hui petit à petit ça prend le
public s'y intéresse il y a de de
l'engouement de de l'engagement par
rapport à à des fidèles qu'on va revenir
régulièrement oui on sent que le Paris
commence à être gagné le vélodrome
est-il devenu la capitale du cyclisme en
France vous votez oui ou non
ouis mustapa non oui
vous êtes tous d'accord vous êtes
partagé on fait un petit duel encore
Jean-Michel contre Yan Jean-Michel vous
commencez bien sûr je je commence la
capitale du cyclisme en France c'est
c'est beaucoup dire bon parce que il y a
des régions de de vélo la Bretagne c'est
la région vélo par excellence encore
aujourd'hui ronalpe alors c'est vrai que
Saint-Quentin c'est le Centre national
de cyclisme avec le cyclisme sur piste
avec le le Stadium de BMX c'est le siège
de de la fédération mais n'exagérons pas
quand quand même bon il y a eu certes
les championnats du monde il y a les
championnats d'Europe mais on est loin
de l'engouement de Manchester par
exemple où le Vélodrome à chaque
manifestation est plein à craquer or
qu'est-ce qu'on voit sur les
championnats d'Europe aujourd'hui on
voit
euh une une enceinte mais même sur les 5
journées
50 % des places des billets ont été
vendus
donc on est loin de la capitale
française du cyclisme la France c'est
une terre de de vélo par excellence mais
il y a d'autres régions qui sont très
très performantes
et au niveau vélo donc attendons pour
qualifier 51 de capital du du cyclisme
c'est exactement ce que j'allais dire en
fait il devrait le devenir puisque c'est
quand même le vélogrum National donc il
a déjà il également eu des courses
internationales je pense notamment à
Paris Brest Paris qui a été organisé en
aût 2015 oui bien sûr sû mais il va y
avoir d'autres choses qui vont être
organisé il va y avoir il va y avoir les
Revolution series qui vont être
organisés c'est la première fois que
c'est c'est mi novembre qui c'est la
première fois qu' une épreuve anglaise
qui qui ne se produisit sort du
territoire anglais pour venir pour venir
en Europe elle vient à Paris au
Vélodrome national là ce sera du sport
spectacle et il va vraiment pas falloir
rater parce que ça va vraiment être très
très sympa il va y avoir plein d'autres
choses qui seront fait sur sur ce
vélodrome mais il faut pas oublier une
chose c'est que ben là on a les
championnats on a eu les championnats du
monde l'année dernière on est championn
d'Europe cette année les championnats du
monde on les reverra pas avant
je dirais au moins 8 ans et les
championnats d'Europe ce sera au moins 4
ans avant avant qu'il reviennent donc il
risque d'y avoir quand même un creux au
niveau des gros événements donc il va
falloir le faire vivre et donc les
Revolution series font partie de de de
de de ce genre de d'événements qui
peuvent être apportés mais aujourd'hui
je vois personne organiser une coupe
d'Europe par exemple sur ce vélodrome
parce que du fait que les spectateurs ne
répondent pas présent et les spectateur
c'est quand même ce qui fait aussi vivre
le vivre les les les événems et bien sûr
il faut faut des des événements majeurs
mais il faut des des événements
régionaux grain de champion il faut
faire participer bon il y a un vivier au
niveau du territoire de saint-quanttin
en iveline au niveau de l'Île-de-France
du département des ivelines un vivier de
pratiquants il faut les amener dans ce
vélodrome faut amener les parents faut
amener les familles il faut amener les
clubs également et tout ça reste à
construire parce qu'on a beaucoup de
problématique pour accéder au Vélodrome
c'est c'est c'est quand même assez
compliqué nous on y est toutes les
semaines avec avec Jean-Michel et il y a
parfois parfois c'est un peu compliqué
entre les les fermetures pour X raisons
mais il faut savoir que c'est quand même
un partenariat public privé et et c'est
quand même pas une une gestion qui est
qui est très très simple c'est pas idéal
c'est pas idéal et et en effet il y a
des il y a des il y a des il y a des
cailloux dans le dans l'engrenage il y a
des caillou dans les engrenages
Guillaume ner ouais ce que je voulais
dire depuis tout à l'heure c'est est-ce
que vraiment ce championn d'Europe
espoir ENF c'est un peu ça finalement
ouiite mais ou finalement c'est pour moi
c'est une compétition de seconde zone
quoi entre guillemets quoi c'est dommage
d'avoir pris acceptter ce championnat
d'Europe à ce momentl en France si on se
prive derrière d' champion d'Europe dans
3 4 ans ou 5 ans avec à une meilleure
date là on savait très bien qu'après les
GO il y aurait pas de Têtre d'affiche
pas de grande
star voilà je suis pas sûr que c'est une
bonne idée d'avoir pris à ce moment-l et
du coup Mustapha les j 2024 vont
peut-être donner plus d'ampleur
peut-être à la structure si la France
est choisie probablement bien sûr mais
ce que ça évoque surtout et ce que ça
m'inspire c'est que on retrouve bien la
un la volonté des dirigeants parce que
c'est quand même une volonté que de
vouloir le devenir celle n'est pas
encore donc si on voudrait que celle
devienne il faut d'abord que ce soit la
volonté de ceux qui nous administrent
deux qui fassent des des choix pour le
coup stratégiques on en revient encore à
la dimension de tous ceux qui gèrent et
qui ont une importance et
troisièmement ce que disait Jean-Michel
et pour moi très important c'est qu'il
faut savoir faire effectivement des des
investissements gérer ça dans le temps
voilà ça ça viendra petit à petit pour
le coup on nous a pas attendu par contre
il y a d'autres il y a d'autres
disciplines ou d'autres lieux où on n
pas les mêmes installations et on en
rêve donc là pour le coup il y a à la
fois probablement la volonté les
installations il faut un peu de temps et
il faut savoir un peu organiser
meilleure communication là la
communication nul enfin j'entend pas
parler quoi que Guillaume Le Doig sur le
le problème majeur actuellement
effectivement euh tout ce qui se passe
au Vélodrome est inconnu mconnu et là il
y a un problème récurrent de
communication euh et ça que que ce soit
par Mme moi je suis à versa voilà et
même les gens du territoire de 50 an
quand même à tirer avec le Grand Prix de
vis notamment que vous organisez
d'ailleurs oui mais euh encore une fois
c'est c'est un tout la la communication
sur sur le vélo sur le BMX sur les les
événements il faut vraiment accentuer
cette communication via les athlètes
parce que des athlètes des têtes
d'affiche vont faire venir du public
mais des jeunes également des jeunes
quand je dis graine de champion il y a
des idées à creuser pour faire venir les
parents les familles il faut trouver
vraiment l'engouement quoi il faut faire
prendre la la mayonnaise et ça passe
aujourd'hui essentiellement on est dans
dans le siècle de la communication il
faut intensifier cette communication
pour que Saint-Quentin dès l'instant où
on parle de SaintQuentin to quand on
parle c'est vrai grand pr de V au Grand
Prix de vé il y aura peut-être peut-être
plus de monde sur une journée que sur la
première que sur la première journée des
championnat d'EUR la sal est chaleureuse
pour au mois de novembre c'est pas faute
de parler vélo
aujourd'huioupour sur toutes les places
prochaines plac qui seront vendu mêmes
j'ai des commissions sur les places pass
maintenant à notre rubrique
Focus après les Championnat du Monde en
février 2015 il y a donc ces championnat
d'Europe à 5qu an en yeline une
compétition qui se dispute avec très peu
de têtes d'affiche on l'a vu nous avons
rencontré Arnaud courtier il va nous
parler de l'ambiance attendue sur ces
prochains jours de compétition il reste
des places on ne sera pas sur
l'affluence extraordinaire des
Championnats du Monde été difficile de
faire aussi bien mais il reste encore
des places donc invite surtout les
cantinois à venir à l'accueil du
Vélodrome national puisqu'il bénéficie
de tarif réduit en tant qu'habitant de
50 ans neline de toutes les communes de
Saint-Quentin ils viennent à l'accueil
du Vélodrome avec un justificatif de
domicile pour bénéficier du tarif réduit
et ils pourront avoir des places on en a
parlé précédemment le public 5
contintinent va-t-il répondre présent
quand même pour ces championnats
d'Europe sur la première journée le
public n'était pas très nombreux est-ce
qu'il y aura plus de monde sur les
prochains jours de compétition Yan
sachez qu'il reste des places ils peuent
ils peuvent y aller ils peuvent les
acheter sur place scolair voilà bien s
il all on espère et on espère et surtout
que le spectacle le spectacle sera au
rendez-vous voilà là premier jour déjàê
d'affiche mais comme on disait
précédemment il y a quand même
F as tu as vu le le spot publicitaire
qu'ils ont fait là avec l'espèce de
bonhomme là ridicule bien sûr mais et
une une finale de vitesse au championnat
de au Jeux Olympiques ça se joue en 10
secondes autour de 10 secondes une
finale de vitesse au au championnat
d'Europe ça jouera en 101 ou 102 hein
faut pas croire que ça va aller moins
vite et qu'il y aura moins de spectacle
parce que c'est les championnat d' donc
vous recommandez à tous les ctinois y y
vous recommandz à tous les ctinois de
venir bien sûr il vous offre
l'entrée Jean-Michel oui ce cyclisme sur
PIST c'est un spectacle avant tout ça
n'a rien à voir avec la route ou parfois
quand on regarde des étapes du Tour de
France on s'ennuie à mourir de dans la
télé là faire des amis r mais je dis ce
que je pense c'est vrai c'est c'est long
il il se passe rien
ÉU un spectacle une éeu spectaculaire
c'est rapide a un enjeu on s'enflamme à
chaque fois que ce soit du sprint que ce
soit de l'élimination du du scratch même
de la vitesse par équipe c'est c'est
c'est beau c'est spectaculaire alors bon
bien sûr on ne peut qu'inciter bah tous
les antinois à venir ce weekend à
remplir le Vélodrome c'est le c'est le
Paris c'est le challenge qu'on lance
Mustapha on parle on parle des T
d'affiche
certes y n'est pas du tout d'accord avec
ces têes d'affiche par contre un Open de
France par exemple avec R makilro qui
est numéro 3 mondial c'est 30 % de
recette en plus clairement Clement
encore une fois il il y a des
locomotives ça draine des wagons
Guillaume disait juste titre d'ailleurs
c'est évoqué par nos amis off parce
qu'il se passe des choses quand la
caméra n'est pas avec vous mesdames
messieurs mais clairement la
communication pose des fonds on disait
est-ce qu'il y aura du monde bah encore
faitil que les gens le sachent mais
juste jeais relevé ça quand même parce
qu'on est quand millions de
téléspectateurs regard le Tour de France
on ne s'emmerde
jamaisainant plusurs disciplin dans vélo
et vous en
préfz il semble
nécessbr danses propos moi le cyclisme à
la télé c'est le tour de France aussi
oui oui mais c'est aussi le Tour de
France JeanMichel on va passer
maintenant notre deè focus conc toujours
le public on remarque généralement que
les Français brillent devant le public 5
en particulier lors des derniers
championnats du monde de cisme sur piste
ils avaient remporté notamment 7
médailles dont 5 en or est-ce qu'il y a
un effet public sur ce type de
compétition Steven Henry le coach de
l'équipe de France d'endurance en est
persuadé je pense à Julien Maurice Il a
2 ans championnat du monde qui fait une
médaille de bronze s'il y a pas le
public il aurait fait 4e concrètement à
la fin il est porté par le public ouais
c'est on va dire le 12e homme si je
emplo une expression du football Yan
quel est l'impact du public sur la
cycliste ben hier c'est un titre de
champion d'Europe un titre de champion
d'Europe ah ben bien sûr Quentin Quentin
démarre avec eu une demise seconde de
retard sur son premier tour une demise
seconde de retard sur le deème tour il y
a aussi un aspect stratégique il avait
un braquet qui était vraiment très gros
et qui ne lui permettait pas d'avoir le
meilleur démarrage un braquet pour un
pour un non spécialiste un braquet un
braquet un braquet il avait un très gros
braquet on ne les connait pas les
braquet les sprinters c'est c'est le
secret top secret c'est voilà et donc il
avait un très gros braquet une bonne
stratégie mais je pense que le public
l'a quand même aidé à à aller chercher
parce que c'est quand même un de ceux
qui a le moins faibli dans le dernier
tour et et je pense que ça l'a poussé et
aidé à aller se dépasser parce qu'il
avait l'air quand même bien bien bien
bien sec à l'arrivée Jean même chose
pour l'équipe de poursuite également qui
a réalisé le meilleur temps des
qualifications hier avec les jeunes que
que nous avons cité une seconde d'avance
sur la deè équipe et euh là aussi le
public les apport porter sur la fin et
on va les revoir aujourd'hui avec une
grande chance de de médaille Guillaume
bah c'est dans toutous les sports pareil
enfin je veux dire dès que c'est
organisé en France ça marche mieux sauf
pourugby en 2007 vous avez été nul mais
bon euh en France 98 on gagne pour quoi
c'est parce qu' enfin on n pas la
meilleure équipe certainement pas et on
gagne parce que c'est en France l'euro
on va en finale on perd en finale mais
bon contre les Portugais ouais mais
parce qu'on joue ça de France de France
il se passe rien il y a pas de il y a
pas d'ambiance et voilà ça s dit oui
c'est dit oui c'est unême il tacle
quandême ah mais ça de France moi j'y
vais plus sauf quand je suis invité on
VI pied parce que sinon c'est ouais non
non mais je veux dire voilà c'est il
faut juste que si si si le le public est
présent et vraiment encourage et est
proche du proche de la des athlètes
forcément c'est un impact hyper positif
sur la performance souvenez-vous des
Championnats du monde d'athlétisme
organisé en France où on avait gagné je
crois presque tous les relis pres x 4
voilà voilà éta c'était magnifique
c'était c'était énorme on a pas perdu
tous les téléspectateurs par qu'on parle
vélo depuis tout à l'heure c'est
important qu'on en parle mais je
voudrais qu'il sache quand même que dans
quelques temps on parlera foot ne zappez
pas
d'accord un cycliste y on ressent
comment quand quand on rentre sur la
piste qu' y a autant de monde alors moi
j'ai malheureusement pas eu beaucoup
d'occasion de faire du vélo devant
beaucoup beaucoup de monde il y a
rarement as des titres de r j'ai des
titres et C
voilà commentess com la dernière fois
que ça m arrivé c'était au mois de juin
la première fois ça arriv
V véodrome qui sont ven pourlaudir moi
mais cétait énorme et sincèrement la
course c'est pas la même
pas régionau nation nation niveau dès
qu'on va dans une contée où y a du monde
spectateur ça joue sur la
performance on va continuer à parler
cyclisme on va parler de la
route
le parcours du Tour de France 2017 a été
dévoilé par les organisateurs le peleton
partira de duselderf en Allemagne il
passera par Chambéry serchevalier à
Briançon le stade Vélodrome de Marseille
mais les coureurs ne traverseront pas
les Yvelines ils passeront par les sones
est-ce que c'est une déception messieurs
oui ou non vous votez Mustapha c'est le
moment de voter
pardon
on va faire un petit duel entre vous
Jean-Michel et vous Guillaume
Jean-Michel vous commencez oui c'est
c'est une déception parce que on aime
bien voir la la dernière étape passer
sur la vallée de Chevreuse monter la
côte de Châteaufort par exemple bon et
puis c'est le CLIN d'œil mais bon la la
dernière étape faut raisonner en
île-de-fance également la dernière étape
partira de mongeron hein mongeron où a
été donné lesin pas très loin les
ivelines dans les sones et qui où a été
donné le le départ du premier du premier
tour de France au réveil matin donc à
partir de là bon mais une petite
déception quand même pour tous les
amoureux du cyclisme dans notre secteur
Guillaume non on a dit tout à l'heure
que le Tour de France n'avait plus du
tout enfin on s'ent bêta entre
guillemets devant le Tour de France
parce qu'il se passe plus rien enfin je
veux dire même en montagne il y a plus
une attaque sur les sur les mecs enfin
il plus rien il passe plus rien pass
plus rien donc qui passe ici ou pas ici
la dernière étape où il B du champagne
franchement en intéress pas non surtout
pour les voir passer en 10 secondes je
vois pas ce que ça change pour le public
ilvinois j'ai une info pour le public
ilvinois allez-y le parisice va démarrer
de saintire l'école l'année ouais
saintti
l'écoleécole en 2017 au MO Mar c'est une
information exclusive de Yan dujar
bienen sur T8 mapha de France on par
tout je je voulais simplement réveiller
les téléspectateurs parce que je vrais
qu'on a un débat sur ne zppez pas er ez
vous avez bien compris qu'on va faire
donc un peu de sémantique et un peu de
voilà donc ne zappez pas on l'a bien
écrit correctement pour en revenir au
Tour de
France évidemment que c'est une
déception par une pour une simple raison
c'est que l'engouement qu'on a sur voilà
en France pour aller l'exporter dans les
pays à l'étranger l'engouement on l'a
sur tout le territoire et tout tous les
territo T les pardon tous les
territoires en rêv moi le premier
simplement c'est pas DESC encore une
fois qui nous reviennent puisque c'est
des décisions qui se font encore une
fois par des stratèges probablement par
du commerce et que il y a certains qui
préfère mettre de la communication et de
l'argent par ailleurs mais bien sûr que
c'est une déception parce qu'on sait
très bien ce que ça charit autour de
cette table on passe notre temps à dire
que c'est important d'avoir une
visibilité sur le sport une visibilité
sur les régions donc en l'occurrence sur
les ivelines et ben oui çaen est une en
particulier parce qu'on en parle
beaucoup faut pas penser que c'est
simplement à la télévision que ça se
passe autour de France ça se passe
également dans les départements dans les
régions dans les dans les fédérations
donc c'est important dire c'est pas
ennuyeux du tout je lance une idée le
départ de la dernière étape faut qu'elle
parte du vélodrome de 50 an voilà pour
faire connaître au monde entier le
Vélodrome et là
on faire Vélodrome à Marseille va
refermer cette large page cyclisme mapha
pour parler des autres résultats
sportifs
iinois
on va parler football club de fin pour
trappe en Coupe de France les joueurs
d'Arnaud évolu en PH se sont inclinés
contre une DH les Murau au 5e tour dans
un match où les ctinois ont fait jeu
égal le score 2 à 1 on écoute les
réactions c'est une défaite logique donc
l'écart de nveau entre une pH et une DH
s vu dans la maîtrise voilà le sang
froid ils ont marqué dans les moments
clés donc après nous on a essayé
d'exister maison il quand Mme un écart
entre une NH on prend le deième but sur
un coup de pied arrêté à 10 minutes de
la fin ça joue sur des détails voilà il
y a on a vu la différence de niveau sur
le deuxième but maintenant c'est à nous
de bosser pour pouvoir les rejoindre un
jour Mustapha que pensez-vous de la
partie de vos joueurs du match de vos
joueurs Contin continu à parler vélo par
franchement j'ai pris le truc là M on
parle de ton club non mais concernant
cette cette prestation qu'ils ont fait
je voudrais en profiter pour remercier à
la fois les spectateurs ils étaient très
nombreux une tribune de plus de 650
personnes donc il y a du monde quand il
y a pour le coup quelque chose qui est
qui est proposé et de qualité donc le
public revient sur sur sur notre stade
j'en profite également pour saluer
Arnaud MB manager général qui fait un
travail assez extraordinaire avec nos
jeunes et on voit bien que on parlait
des jeunes tout à l'heure le travail
fait par Arnaud et et ses équipes sur
les jeunes amène une équipe senior
constituée quasiment totalement des
jeunes de trappe donc c'est une manière
de également de boucler de boucler à la
fois les propos qu'on peut avoir ici
mais la réalité du terrain euh
maintenant pour en revenir au score on a
fait une prestation où on est battu par
une DH une DH très très grosse une
grosse écurie les muraux voilà qui
évolue dans un dans un championnat très
très musclé au passage Versailles en est
la locomotive dans ce championnat 21 on
n'est pas parti
ridicule franchement c'est ça tient très
peu de chose la preuve c'est que ce
penalty en fin de match aurait très bien
pu ouis a très bien pu faire basculer à
la dernière seconde mais avec des S on
refit pas le match mais globalement un
22 changer la physionomie du match il y
a il y a 2 ans c'était n DH également et
c'était Versailles ça s'est joué au
penalty donc une très belle prestation
mais encore une fois il faut pas oublier
tous les enjeux d'un d'un club et entre
guillemets à mon niveau et à celui de
l'encadrement la Coupe de France c'est
une chose mais il y a un championnat
derrière et et c'est vrai que il faut
probablement savoir faire des choix on n
pas
choisi de perdre mais c'est vrai que des
fois c'est un mal pour un bien c'est
qu'on va pouvoir se reconcentrer sur le
championnat et c'est le championnat qui
est extrêmement important pour nous on
vise une montée cette année évidemment
et voilà et je vous remercie de par les
football de temps en
tempsion de temps en temps on va faire
rapide sur cette fin d'émission du
ballon on passe au ballon al tout va
bien pour le Sky rugby dans le
championnat de Promotion d'Honneur les
cinquentinois se sont facilement imposés
contre marcousi ce dimanche le score est
sans appel 45 à 10 au classement le Sky
est premier avec trois victoires en
trois matchs et 14 points engrangés nous
avons interroger Thomas paayen sur le
début de saison canon de l'équipe c'est
dans la continuité de la saison dernière
où on a fait une grosse grosse saison on
a perdu peu de matchs donc il y a une
grosse grosse préparation cet été
beaucoup de physique beaucoup de jeu
avec ballon également ça é assez lourd
pour les joueurs mais du coup c'est
payant d'entrée de saison on n'a pas
encore joué les meilleures équipes de de
la poule je pense du coup pour nous
c'est une bonne entrée en matière ça
nous permett rentrer progressivement
dans dans le championnat Guillaume sur
ce début de saison à canon du est-ce
vous a raction bravo à eux c'est aussi
logique puisque le classement est fait
que les meilleurs la son passé
rencontrre les les moins bons de la son
passé du coup comme ils ont fini premier
quasiment l'année dernière ils
rencontrent le bas de tableau d'abord et
on verra à partir de la fin des match
all quand ils vont rencontrer les gros
que on verra là si vraiment ils sont au
niveau de leur le leurs intentions en
tout cas de remonter en division
d'honneur c'est une surprise de les voir
à ce niveau-là ah non l'ann dernière ils
ont monté ils ont une défaite qui monte
pas donc non il ils sont bien dans le
dans leur championnat et j'espère pour
eux cette année ça va ça va payer et
est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque que les
joueurs s'ennuient sur sur cette saison
l'anne dernière ils n'ont pas loupé ils
ont loupé la montée pour une seule
défaite est-ce qu'il y a pas ce risque
là sans nouer non parce que c'est
toujours plus sympa comme des saison on
gagne que des saisons on perd donc tant
que ça gagne ils sont pas vous inquiétez
pas les trè miemps je pense que sont
sont sympathiques peut-être que vous les
rejoindrez font la fête pour pour la
montée c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
le jeudi 3 novembre pour un nouveau
numéro de si on parlait sport à bientôt
sur TVF 78 très belle
soirée